you know if you had the misfortune of
living in 17th century colonial
massachusetts
uh it would not have taken much for you
to be labeled a witch
those suspected of witchcraft and
executed for it didn't need to be seen
flying through the air in a broom
some were burned simply for associating
with others who were suspected of being
witches
some for having certain physical traits
thought to be marks of
witchery your age your gender your
social class your family all of these
were thought to be
passive clues potentially indicating
that you are a witch
or possibly a witch or which adjacent
now we would like to think that
things are different now in our
enlightened times but
humans are humans and the witch trials
were born from the very human tendency
to invent
new enemies in our heads and then to
suddenly find them
everywhere we turn we have many such
boogeymen
in our culture they're they're they're
more likely to be punished with mockery
and alienation rather than incineration
but as we've seen the latter option
incineration
hasn't been taken off the table entirely
especially recently
the actor chris pratt has experienced
all of this this week and not for the
first time experiencing the wrath of the
modern witch hunters
his suspected crime being a christian a
conservative and worst of all
a trump voter now while pratt is a
professed christian
and does seem to perhaps be more
politically conservative than the
average hollywood celebrity which is
sort of like calling him
cleaner than the average dumpster cat
there's no reason to actually think that
chris pratt supports trump
there's even less reason to care if he
does or doesn't but the witch hunters on
the left
cannot tolerate dissent even
theoretically and especially not from
someone
in a profession or demographic group of
which they have claimed
claimed ownership and that is why pratt
has been trending on social media all
week for days now not because leftists
are outraged by things that he has said
or beliefs he has professed
which would be bad enough if that were
the reason but because of their
suspicions about beliefs he might hold
as twitter describes it you can see
there here on their trending section
uh the chris chris pratt controversy
that has sparked over 260 000 tweets
is focused on quote his alleged
political and religious beliefs
now this seems to have started with news
that some avenger actors are taking part
in a joe biden
virtual fundraiser cringily titled
voters assemble
marvel luminaries like chris evans
scarlett johansson mark ruffalo don
cheadle paul rudd
zoe saldana all volunteered for the
noble clause
but a few actors were missing from the
biden fundraiser roster and this fact
became cause for great concern
now it was apparently decided that some
of the missing superheroes
should be given an excused absence
because they're not from this country
like the guy who plays spider-man
spider-man's off the hook
but chris pratt has no such alibi
and this raised suspicion as an article
in the av club put it quote
the fundraiser will feature a trivia
game and q a which we hope will at least
be partially dedicated to asking about
every single member of the avengers
who isn't there a good number of them
aren't from the u.s so we can't expect
them to clean up our mess in this dumb
country
but this is the second one of these
biden fundraiser reunion things
that chris pratt has missed out on we
theorized last time that he's either a
republican
or just wants everyone to get along and
can't endorse anyone since he's all
buff and churchy now but we'll have to
wait and see what happens if the biden
campaign organizes an everwood reunion
from there it was off to the races with
great numbers of people
attacking chris pratt for what they
assume his political views
probably are and the circumstantial
evidence that pratt secretly wears maga
hats in his spare time
goes beyond his absence at a biden
fundraiser we should note he also uh
he also attends according to leftist
critics including fellow actor ellen
page
in anti-lgbt church so that's a red flag
plus as vanity fair points out quote
pratt's personal life has also led to
speculation about his politics
last year pratt married catherine
schwarzenegger daughter of
daughter of arnold schwarzenegger a
long-time republican
though the article points out that
catherine publicly supports biden
so at least someone in the pratt
household isn't the white supremacist
that's good
other media outlets have have weighed in
now listen to this
newsweek ran a fact check
analyzing the claims that pratt is quote
allegedly
a republican and trump supporter the
article sifts through all the clues
you know looking at all the different
evidence eventually landing on the
verdict of
unknown newsweek says we cannot verify
if pratt is a trump supporter because he
hasn't confirmed it
the hollywood actor has not shown any
support publicly for the president for
the president or his democratic
challenger joe biden
but unknown isn't good enough
especially when pratt as some on twitter
have pointed out
follows uh notorious nazis like ben
shapiro and
dan crenshaw if pratt wants to absolve
himself of his assumed thought crimes
he has to come out and publicly support
biden and denounce
trump anything less will be
insufficient now to the credit many of
pratt's castmates have come to his
defense
against the slobbering mindless hordes
but they've come in for harsh criticism
because of that especially zoe saldana
who
was attacked with racial slurs by the
racially tolerant left
one person calling her a nasty biracial
woman
another saying there quote tired of
defending your crack-a-loving ass
adding of course shut up along with many
other comments that i i
just can't read out loud all of this
again it cannot be emphasized enough
merely because of political views that
the man
might hold so gone are the days when
people can be viciously attacked
for the opinions they express well those
days are still here but we're now living
in a time when you could be attacked for
opinions you did not express
silence is violence as the slogan goes
and the people who say that
really mean it now i don't say this just
because i'm a conservative it really is
true
that only one side of the ideological
divide behaves this way
and that's at least partially a
reflection of just how dominant
and mainstream leftism is it still
positions itself of course as the
counterculture but it isn't
it is the culture and now having won
every major battle and seized nearly all
of the cultural power
it can concern itself with issues like
chris pratt's theoretical political
leanings
only the dominant culture and the
dominant cultural narrative can
demand allegiance to this extent
counter-culture movements aren't usually
the ones conducting witch hunts
and this is what makes all the talk
about resistance from the left so absurd
what are you resisting what is the
resistance resisting
you own everything just this week sony
became the latest of dozens and dozens
of billion
corporations to endorse black lives
matter and this only a few days after it
was announced
that one of the marxist co-founders of
blm has inked a major deal with warner
brothers
what type of counter culture movement
has billion-dollar sponsors
and contracts with major hollywood
studios a fraudulent one
that's what type the left dresses up in
costumes the costume of outsiders and
radicals and complains about alleged
depression
and then they charge out into the street
to fight enemies they've already
defeated
and monsters that don't exist so instead
they burn down a cvs
steal a few arm loads of shoes call it a
day go home
tweet about why a marvel actor is
persecuting them by not saying anything
at all
this is the behavior of the comfortable
the victorious
and the board and that's what leftism is
but what it is not certainly most of all
is counter culture
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt walsh show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content